[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here and this here
is an apple watch series 7.
so if watches did s updates like that
this would be a series 6s for sure but
they don't either way what you need to
know is
it's a minor update matter of fact at
the risk of tanking this video's watch
time
watch time uh this watch is basically a
series six
but with a slightly larger display and
slightly faster charging
same price
that's basically it but there are a
bunch of other little quirks and things
you should know about it if you're
considering actually getting one
but yeah like i said the flagship new
thing about the apple watch series 7 is
that it's bigger alright mostly with the
screen too so you get this 20 larger
display in a watch that's just barely
bigger than the previous body and right
away you do notice that everywhere the
whole ui is a little bigger you know in
the calculator the buttons are a little
bit bigger in your notifications there's
just a little bit more text the map if
you're navigating is that much more
usable and when you're typing your
passcode of course the digits are just
that much bigger so for me i like that
the snooze button is also slightly
larger in the alarm clock but just being
slightly bigger with smaller bezels
wouldn't be quite enough for a whole new
watch so apple did the apple thing and
built a few special features into the
series seven that specifically worked
best for the larger display so they made
two exclusive watch faces for the series
seven only to take advantage of this
screen this one here is called contour
where the numbers literally wrap all the
way around the very edges and then
there's this modular duo watch face
which basically has two really large
data rich center complications so i can
keep track of exactly how well i'm
crushing my fitness competitions all the
time
then they made a full qwerty keyboard
for the watch now that sounds terrible
at first and it actually looks a little
bit ridiculous on your wrist when you go
to reply to a text but it is a swipe
keyboard which is easier to crank out
words on you're swiping between letters
of the words and auto predict is usually
pretty decent
i just personally didn't find myself
actually using this very much like it is
enough to get a couple words down but if
you get enough words wrong
the ui is barely big enough to go back
through and select the words you want to
replace and then you tap in and then
re-swipe them
and you're holding your wrist up this
whole time and
i don't know it's fine it's fine for
quick messages but i'm still gonna go
with voice text nine times out of ten
either way i think we all knew that
having a slightly bigger screen would be
a pretty basic upgrade for a smartwatch
but what i was a little more curious
about especially after seeing all of
those apple promo videos was actually
the shape of this new display so
if you've seen the videos then you're
familiar they've pushed the screen right
up all the way to the very edges here
and so it gets so close to the edges
that apple was showing readable text
literally bleeding over the edges and
corners of the watch like readable from
the side which looks awesome in rendered
videos with no reflections but i was
very curious about all the reflections
and stray light and refractions that
happen in real life
turns out it didn't really make much of
a difference at all i mean yes the apple
watch has always had this shape with the
curved edges and this year the display
does push more up into those corners
than ever before but it doesn't make
much of a difference with readability
where most of the stuff is in the center
of the screen literally the one place i
found it to make the biggest difference
is in the exclusive contour watch face
that puts the numbers all the way around
the most reflective edges of the display
so then yeah you're gonna have to learn
to deal with some more annoying
reflections on a regular basis just to
see what time it is i like the bigger
screen though bottom line now something
to consider
if you have like smaller wrists or if
you're a little more sensitive to the
size of this big watch like
it's starting to look like a computer on
your wrist if you're getting the biggest
watch and so you might consider getting
this smaller apple watch instead because
that screen size is up to 41 millimeters
now which is still very usable that's
actually fun fact
one millimeter smaller than the original
large sized apple watch now when i said
there's a couple other small changes i
really meant it there's just a couple
small things but the thing about small
changes is if enough of them apply to
you then they can add up to make a
bigger change which is nice
but if they don't apply to you you might
not care you'll probably know pretty
quickly which can't be fallen so this is
now the most durable apple watch ever so
i noticed the speaker on the left is now
a single slot where previous versions
were two slots but that's apparently not
contributing to durability it's actually
the thicker cover glass and you can
never tell just by looking at it from
the outside because it doesn't protrude
anymore it actually goes deeper into the
watch and that larger z-axis dimension
makes it more crack resistant than ever
before so if you tend to put your watch
through a lot maybe you play a lot of
sports with it on you're lifting with it
you hit stuff with it maybe you're tough
on it outdoors maybe you're my sister
and the entire cover glass just breaks
off of your watch for no reason then
yeah this may be important to you
and then the watch is now
ip6x dust resistant not because of some
new hardware or coding but actually
apple's never tested the watch for dust
resistance before so it's just kind of a
bonus to now have that extra peace of
mind they've always tested for water
resistance though like people ask me
sometimes if they can get the watch wet
or shower with it uh yes you can
literally dive underwater with an apple
watch and it'll be fine it's rated for
50 meters deep of water resistance so
it's no garmin but the things have been
pretty tough for a while this watch is
also now brighter when you're not
looking at it
it's subtle but you know so if you have
always on you know how it gets dimmer
when you're not looking at it and then
gets brighter when you're checking it
when you're checking it same brightness
max is the same but when you put it down
and it's sort of dimmer it's a bit
brighter in that dim state than the
previous one
so if you're someone who likes to just
glance over at the watch without doing
like an obvious gesture then yeah you
can check the time or your complications
or notifications easier that way it
barely shows on camera but this new
watch is slightly slightly more readable
from off axis when it's dim it's
noticeable when you put them next to
each other but wasn't a huge deal for me
but the little thing that applied to me
the most it charges 33 faster now
so same battery life about a day and a
half you can kill it much faster if you
do workouts or gps tracked activity
stuff like that but with and only with
the new usbc charger included in the box
with this new puck the watch does charge
up a bit faster it's not super dramatic
it'll still take about an hour to charge
it up fully from dead but if you're like
me i'm a person that wears a watch like
24 hours a day all the time i sleep in
it too so it's my alarm clock i hate
going to sleep with it on but it is a
great alarm clock just tapping me on the
wrist so
the only times i really get to charge it
are very brief it'll be like when i'm in
the shower or when i get up in the
morning for a couple minutes so i want
it to charge fast when i do get a chance
to charge so this charging speed boost
is appreciated uh eight minutes on the
new charger is enough for eight hours of
sleep tracking with the screen off so
that's pretty great just make sure you
have a decent usbc power brick and your
set you wanna know my biggest
disappointment actually with these
watches though
the color choices so you may have
noticed i'm wearing the
product red version of the watch it's
very bold bright red but i feel like
with a watch
you you wear it every day you want it to
be a little more neutral a little more
able to match with more things and then
if you want to spice it up you do that
with the watch band like this beautiful
new mkbhd leather strap from moment with
the full grain soft embossed leather and
trademarked parallelogram tessellation
pattern and that crisp red accent link
in the description also shout out to
moment for co-designing this but apple
doesn't offer a neutral color for the
aluminum baseline apple watch
i repeat
no
neutral colored
aluminum so aluminum is the baseline
it's 400 bucks and i define neutral as
like a shade of black or gray or white
so i know some people might consider the
starlight pretty neutral but it
definitely has a warmer hue than a
silver wood and midnight has a slight
blue hue much more than a black wood so
the only way to get a genuine neutral
shade of gray would be to jump to
titanium or stainless steel which is not
only heavier but much more expensive so
it just bothers me that i can't get a
baseline black aluminum apple watch
it's you know maybe i'm being picky
about the color but since i am that
picky i'll probably just stick with the
series six but that's not on sale
anymore so if you want to get one
good luck so now on apple site they're
selling the lineup of series seven
se
and the low end series 3. so if you can
avoid the series 3 you know unless it's
your first smartwatch in which case you
probably won't know what you're missing
that's fine but the main differences
between series 7 and se are the larger
always on display
this set of colors of course and there's
a couple extra sensors like for blood
oxygen and the electrocardiogram the
watch se is great for almost everyone
but if you can get past these colors
then yeah the series 7 is it's the best
overall smart watch for the iphone still
i mean it doesn't have any crazy new
features it doesn't have you know
charging on the back of the iphone it
doesn't have the new square redesign we
might have been hoping for
but yeah it's the apple watch
but bigger
there you go but yeah there's a new
apple event
literally next week so if you're hoping
for some more exciting stuff maybe we'll
see some of it there but that's pretty
much it for this one catch you guys very
soon in the next one because it's
tectober and this stuff just keeps
rolling
catch you guys then
peace